amigas amigos de visual político tengo
que enunciar es algo muy importante
donald trump ha vuelto
[Aplausos]
[Música]
si habéis oído bien donald trump ha
vuelto a dar de qué hablar y diréis pero
porque esta vez pues por esto trump
denuncia twitter google y facebook
alegando censura como sabéis tras el
asalto al capitolio todas las grandes
plataformas de internet eliminaron todas
las cuentas asociadas a donald trump por
qué pues porque donald trump estuvo
agitando a sus seguidores horas antes de
que tomaran el capitolio de forma
violenta
[Música]
es decir no es que le acusen de haber
organizado el asalto pero si le culpan
por haber creado el clima de odio que
provocó el ataque y esto abre un debate
muy serio porque hasta qué punto estamos
hablando de censura
[Música]
y ya sé lo que me diréis mucho saber
fonseca son empresas privadas tanto
facebook como twitter o como youtube
pueden tener todas las normas que
quieran y si tenéis razón el problema el
problema es que estas tres plataformas
tienen prácticamente el oligopolio del
contenido online es decir que si youtube
por ejemplo cerrar un canal sería muy
difícil prácticamente imposible que ese
canal encontrara otra plataforma
parecida desde donde emitir por internet
pero esperad un momento porque no
hablamos sólo de un capricho de las
grandes tecnológicas en realidad tanto
twitter como facebook como google están
entre la espada y la pared
[Música]
por un lado camps y muchos otros les
denuncian por violar la libertad de
expresión pero por el otro lado muchos
gobiernos les presionan para que
eliminen todo lo que se considera
contenido nocivo atentos facebook y
youtube encaran nuevas estrictas leyes
sobre vídeos explícitos o extremistas
europa propone nuevas reglas y multas
para forzar a las redes sociales a
moderar los vídeos online para que os
hagáis una idea algunas de estas leyes
contemplan multas de hasta 50 millones
de euros y la pregunta es de verdad
hablamos de censura hasta qué punto es
razonable exigir que por ejemplo youtube
nos proteja del contenido nocivo hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
cuánta libertad de expresión es
demasiada en noviembre del año 2015 una
chica española fue detenida en el
aeropuerto de barajas en madrid cuando
estaba a punto de viajar a turquía para
unirse al da es lo más increíble de esta
historia es que la chica en cuestión ni
siquiera había nacido en una familia
musulmana esta chica se radicalizó
viendo propagando del dax en redes
sociales y es que recordaréis que hubo
un tiempo hace no tantos años en el que
era absurdamente fácil encontrar vídeos
de propaganda islamista radical por
internet estaban en el mismísimo
instagram
por supuesto que en casi todos los
países democráticos hay leyes que
prohíben la propaganda terrorista es
decir que aunque la constitución de
cualquier país europeo reconozca la
libertad de expresión hay algunos
límites y la llaman explícita a la
violencia es uno de ellos el problema el
problema es que por muchas leyes que
haya es muy difícil impedir que alguien
cree un vídeo de propaganda terrorista y
se haga viral en redes sociales es la
otra cara de toda esa libertad que nos
da internet por aquellos años solo una
plataforma tenía los algoritmos para
detectar los vídeos del dax a tiempo y
si esa plataforma es esta plataforma
desde donde me estáis viendo ahora mismo
youtube y diréis por qué pues es tema
para otro vídeo pero lo cierto es que
tanto facebook como instagram como
twitter no se habían preocupado por
evitar que los grupos extremistas como
el daes o tantos otros camparan a sus
anchas que así es como saltaron las
alarmas en muchos gobiernos
rezando bien por mucho que la policia
persiguiera a los terroristas cada dia
surgían nuevos efectos salda es que se
habían radicalizado por internet y así
es como en varios países en europa
sacaron sus propias leyes para
responsabilizar a facebook twitter y
youtube del contenido que tenían en sus
respectivas plataformas el primer país y
el más importante fue alemania
[Música]
pensadlo bien desde los años 50 alemania
tiene leyes muy estrictas para evitar
discursos neonazis negaran holocausto en
este país puede llegar a castigarse con
años de cárcel y en algunos casos esas
leyes han llegado a situaciones tan
absurdas como esta wolfenstein retirado
de la venta en alemania debido a los
símbolos nazis por cierto que desde el
año 2019 alemania ha suavizado bastante
estas leyes y ahora por fin el
wolfenstein 3d vuelve a ser legal en
alemania menos mal lo cierto es que
alemania siempre ha tenido bastantes
restricciones para evitar los discursos
extremistas así que en el año 2017
decidieron también ser pioneros en una
restricción más si mis queridos amigos
de visual política hablamos de la
llamada ley net z deje si así es como se
conoce esta ley y en todo el mundo según
esta ley tanto youtube como facebook o
twitter están obligados a retirar el
contenido dañino en menos de 24 horas
después de la notificación de las
autoridades y si no lo hacen pueden
tener que pagar multas y hasta 50
millones de euros el problema el
problema es que lo que empecé podría ser
una ley solamente para evitar la
propaganda terrorista termina
convirtiéndose en algo mucho peor
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea semanas
después de que se aprobara esta ley
tanto twitter como facebook le quitaron
la cuenta a una diputada del partido
alternativa por alemania por lanzar
mensajes contra los inmigrantes pero es
que días después twitter también eliminó
la cuenta de la revista satírica que
había mencionado a esa política para
reírse de ella y unos días más tarde
twitter también le cerró la cuenta a
otra humorista que ésta había sido un
chiste sobre alternativa por alemania-
conclusión que si tienes twitter en
alemania mejor no hables de inmigrantes
ni a favor ni en contra pero no creáis
que hablamos solamente de un par de
casos extremos para que os hagáis una
idea solo en los seis primeros meses del
año 2019 youtube tuvo que borrar más de
280 vídeos y vaya por delante que
youtube es la única empresa de estas
tres víctimas
diferencias entre facebook twitter
youtube a la hora de moderar el
contenido hablaremos en otro vídeo que
por cierto vamos a sacar muy pronto así
que si nos lo queréis perder ya sabéis
suscribiros a este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones pero volvamos
con la historia porque lo cierto es que
esta ley alemana escuela en el año 2020
francia sacó otra ley para luchar contra
discurso de odio la diferencia es que en
este caso el tribunal constitucional
francés consiguió tumbar la y aquí es
donde entra el otro gran problema con
las legislaciones que quieres regular
las pequeños la desinformación y el
discurso de odio
[Música]
la mayor parte de los países
democráticos tienen constituciones que
reconocen la libertad de expresión por
supuesto todas ellas reconocen ciertas
excepciones como por ejemplo el discurso
al honor o los discursos de odio
claramente explícitos y estipulados pero
en este caso estamos hablando de algo
mucho más profundo hablamos de poder
censurar contenido por motivos en muchos
casos difíciles de definir sin embargo
dentro de la unión europea hay cada vez
más voces que piden políticas reales
para frenar lo que llaman el contenido
dañino en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo europa está tramitando la ley
de servicios digitales que
responsabiliza a las plataformas sobre
el contenido que tienen alojado pero el
debate sigue abierto muchos políticos
tienen miedo de que esta ley sirva para
callar ciertas posturas políticas como
puedan ser el euroescepticismo o los
discursos anti inmigración y las
plataformas online tampoco pueden
responsabilizarse de las miles de horas
de contenido que tienen en sus
servidores eso por no hablar del difícil
encaje que tendría esta ley en las
constituciones de muchos de los estados
miembros vamos que todavía no existe
ningún tipo de consenso político este
respecto y por eso en primavera del año
2021 la comisión europea ha publicado el
estudio sobre la responsabilidad de las
plataformas con la que habéis oído bien
la doctrina está clara las plataformas
online son responsables por el contenido
que tienen alojado no sólo deben actuar
cuando hay una violación de copyright
sino también cuando hay una violación de
la decencia inmoral pública así que este
estudio propone cuatro escenarios
distintos escenario a no hacer nada
escenario ve a hacer campañas de
educación mediática entre la población
es lo que dice el escenario ce
regulación público-privada y escenario
de
habéis oído bien por el momento el
escenario que más se baraja en europa es
que las propias plataformas sean quienes
se autorregulen es decir que cree en una
serie de normas y se encarguen ellas
solitas de borrar todo el contenido
malicioso que se haya podido colar y
diréis bueno y dónde está el problema
entonces siempre será mejor la
autocensura que la censura verdad pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
los orígenes del final feliz y si os
dijera que el final feliz ese final
feliz tan típico de las películas de
hollywood nació como respuesta a la
censura habéis oído bien el final feliz
nació en una época donde las películas
simplemente no podían terminar mal no al
menos si querían recibir el sello de
aprobación para poderse proyectar en el
cine os voy a dar un ejemplo mister
speed goes to washington es una película
de frank capra en españa' se llamó
caballeros en espacio
esta película cuenta la historia de un
político idealista que se tiene que
enfrentar a todos los senadores
corruptos de washington en principio no
aparece ningún tema censurable verdad
bueno recordad que esta película es del
año 1939 criticar el funcionamiento del
sistema americano podía verse como
propaganda comunista
en aquel momento las películas tenían
que transmitir valores morales yo
significan que los malos tenían que ser
castigados el bueno tenía que ganar y la
moraleja de la historia debería ser
moral ella sé lo que estaréis pensando
muchos pero esto cómo es posible si algo
caracteriza a eeuu es la libertad de
expresión está bien clarita en la
primera enmienda de la constitución y si
tenéis razón el problema el problema
viene cuando consideras que el cine no
es un medio de expresión
ya lo sé pensaréis que me he vuelto loco
pero esto es exactamente lo que ocurrió
no olvidéis una cosa estamos hablando de
principios del siglo 20 por aquel
entonces el cine era una nueva
tecnología tal como ahora pueden ser las
plataformas de contenido online en
internet y precisamente esa fue la
doctrina judicial que dictó la corte
suprema de los estados unidos en 1915
atentos al veredicto final la exhibición
de películas es un negocio simple y
llanamente y no se puede considerar como
parte de la prensa del país o como un
órgano de opinión pública dentro de los
parámetros de la libertad de expresión
mutual film corporation versus
industrial comisión ohio 1915 si habéis
oído bien el cine no se consideraba un
medio de expresión pero esperad un
momento porque la historia no termina
aquí habéis oído hablar alguna vez del
mito pues tampoco es algo nuevo él
harvey weinstein de 1920 era un actor de
comedia llamado roscoe fatty arbuckle
el escándalo para ti era la historia
escabrosa perfecta que incluía sexo
asesinatos y estrellas de hollywood
electo ctc el perfecto para vender
periódicos ya que no adivina quién fue
el magnate de los medios que más réditos
sacó de esta historia exacto william
randolph hearst por aquel entonces ya
tenía varios periódicos en todo el país
de un día para otro los escándalos
sexuales de hollywood se convirtieron en
el tema de conversación de todos los
bares y peluquerías de eeuu recordar
este nombre el de william randolph
hearst porque hablaremos de él en un
vídeo que sacaremos pronto todo el país
estaba escandalizado con la falta de
moral de las estrellas en mitad de este
pánico moral los estados decidieron
empezar a legislar
como el film ya no se consideraba un
medio de comunicación los distintos
estados de eeuu pudieron aprobar toda
clase de leyes de censura para el año
1921 ya había 37 estados con censura y
en este momento es cuando hollywood
decidió actuar y así es como la musique
cels association of america creó un
código de buenas prácticas os suena de
algo esta historia y os preguntaréis
pero como se crea un código de buenas
prácticas morales en los años 20 pues
muy fácil quienes eran los mayores
expertos en moral pública de aquel
momento pues obviamente los curas así es
cómo hollywood contrató a este señor que
veis en pantalla
william harrison que es un sacerdote
presbiteriano y no creáis que repararon
en gastos
el señor hayes llegó a cobrar un sueldo
de 100 dólares al año de la época en
dólares de hoy en día estaríamos
hablando de más de 1,5 millones de
dólares al año además este hombre
contrató a todo un equipo de sacerdotes
para que le ayudaran a crear el código
un código que se tardó años en terminar
y que desde entonces se conoce como el
código hays un código de censo con
normas tan detalladas como esta los
personajes de sacerdotes no podrán ser
utilizados como personajes cómicos o
villanos extracto del código de
producción de películas desde el año
1934 todas las películas tenían que
pasar por un tribunal de sacerdotes para
que le pusieran el sello moral y fijaos
bien en un detalle hablamos de algo
mucho peor que censura porque la censura
de hollywood no se limitaba a eliminar
oa quitar una escena concreta o a
prohibir tal o cual cosa al ser algo
aceptado por las propias productoras la
censura afectaba a toda la historia por
ejemplo habéis visto el halcón maltés'
si lees el libro en el que está basado
veréis que hay un personaje abiertamente
homosexual recordad que la literatura si
estaba considerada como un medio de
comunicación así que las novelas sí que
disfrutaban de libertad de expresión sin
embargo en la película ese mismo
personaje no podía ser ni abiertamente
homosexual ni por supuesto el bueno así
que termina siendo un señor simplemente
afeminado y por supuesto el malo de la
película
[Música]
desde los años 30 hasta los años 60 del
siglo 20 podéis encontrar cientos de
ejemplos como este por suerte en los
años 60 la corte suprema- cambió su
doctrina y hoy en día el cine de eeuu
disfruta de la misma libertad de
expresión que cualquier otro medio de
comunicación sin embargo parece que
ahora mismo la historia se repite pero
esta vez con otra nueva tecnología la
comisión europea y las empresas
tecnológicas anuncian un código de
conducta contra el discurso de odio
ilegal comisión europea 31 de mayo de
2016 habéis oído bien pero antes de que
se echase las manos a la cabeza dejadme
que os diga que por el momento este
código es bastante amplio dentro de lo
que cabe es decir por el momento los
únicos límites marcados son evitar la
propaganda de grupos terroristas
mensajes de odio claros y explícitos que
ya estaban prohibidos por las anteriores
legislaciones en casi todos los países y
cosas por el estilo el problema el
problema es que este código es del año
2016 pero es que ahora estamos en 2021 y
europa pide todavía más restricciones
para reforzar el código de prácticas en
materia de desinformación comisión
europea 25 de mayo 21 21 ahora el gran
problema que europa quiere solucionar ya
no es el discurso de odio sino la
desinformación es decir las fake news y
las teorías de la conspiración que han
crecido como la espuma en época de
coronavirus el problema es quien dice lo
que es verdad y lo que no es verdad de
verdad se puede juzgar esto sin estar
libre de sesgos y cómo pueden auto
regularse las plataformas de internet en
este caso de eso hablaremos la próxima
semana aquí en visual político y vamos a
ver con todo el lujo de detalles las
diferencias entre estos tres personajes
aquí podéis ver a la ceo de youtube el
ceo de facebook y el ceo de twitter pero
mientras tanto podéis dejarme vuestra
opinión en los comentarios
como creéis que se pueden filtrar las
técnicas en internet de verdad
deberíamos hacerlo podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
mientras tanto no olvidéis que aquí en
visual politics sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribiros a
este canal y darle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo darle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto